la bataille sur l'augmentation de des
salaires des députés de l'Assemblée
nationale ferrage Québec solidaire c'est
même pays un sondage pour se donner des
munitions ce coût de sonde conclut
environ les trois quarts des personnes
sont des sons contre l'augmentation de
30 000 dollars du salaire de base d'un
élu dans les tranchées de cette bataille
QS fait aussi de l'obstruction en
commission parlementaire pour retarder
le plus possible le projet de loi
l'adoption du projet de loi que qui
consacre l'augmentation le projet de loi
présenté par le gouvernement François
Legault qui aime les sondages qui se dit
à l'écoute des Québécois sera-t-il ému à
lançonder notre état-major Michel
Jean-François Dimitri et Françoise bon
début d'après-midi à vous quatre bonjour
bonjour
salut et voici tout le monde de garde à
vous voici le sondage de Québec
solidaire sondage Léger êtes-vous en
accord d'augmenter de 30% le salaire des
députés en accord 20% en désaccord 74%
Michel est-ce que vous comprenez
pourquoi Québec solidaire s'acharne
combattre ce projet de loi puis il met
toute la gomme là un sondage c'est pas
c'est pas anodin non c'est un sondage
Léger quand même ça une certaine
crédibilité donc
c'est intéressant de voir j'avoue
qu'elle soit 74 % et élevé maintenant
Québec soldat j'ai écouté attentivement
ce matin pour une presse que Gabriel
Nadaud Dubois a fait j'avoue
qu'aujourd'hui sont plus difficiles à
suivre
parce que comme ça on parlementaire ils
ont aussi proposé un amendement dans
lequel il suggère une augmentation de 20
000 dollars au lieu de 30000 dollars moi
le saut j'avoue que ça vient de faire
tomber complètement pour moi
l'importance de leur démarche parce que
tu peux pas tu peux pas dire tout et son
contraire en même temps alors pourquoi
tout à coup pourquoi justement pourquoi
la question a été posée à Gabriel Nanou
Dupont
en effet l'impression que QS
pelure de bananise un peu en présentant
un amendement qui demande une
augmentation il y avait deux amendements
en fait 10000 dollars ou 20 000 et 20000
dollars parce qu'il faut comprendre
qu'ils essaient de faire du temps comme
ils sont parlementaires donc ils
présentent toutes sortes d'amendements
puis là on en discute mais ils ont
présenté ses amendements et la question
a été posée à Gabriel Nadaud Dubois
pourquoi vous êtes contre 30000 dollars
d'augmentation mais vous seriez pour
20000 dollars écoutons la réponse de
Monsieur nadaudit qu'on a fait en
commission parlementaire c'est
travailler très fort pour amoindrir le
plus possible l'impact du projet de loi
kakiste et libéral sur les contribuables
québécois donc oui on a travaillé fort
on a déposé des amendements pour essayer
d'amoindrir le plus possible à hausse on
n'est pas gêné de ça ce qui devrait être
gêné c'est les libéraux et la CAQ qui se
battent
mordicus coûte que coûte pour avoir à
tout prix dans leur poche une
augmentation de 30 000 dollars
qui est bien appris son rôle aussi il
est toujours là comme ça en train de
faire comme ça
mais Sébastien
la semaine dernière puis la semaine
d'avant ils étaient totalement contre
alors ça tient pas la route d'arriver de
dire en commission parlementaire on veut
à moins de rire cette hausse là il l'a
moins de risque de 10000 dollars il a
moins de risque même pas de moitié alors
sincèrement je n'arrive pas à suivre
leur stratégie parce qu'il y a d'autres
façons d'étirer le temps en commission
parlementaire et il y aurait proposé ben
d'autres amendements en commission
parlementaire et je ne comprends
toujours pas comment se fait-il que ce
que ce soit le PQ ou Québec solidaire ne
propose pas en amendement un comité
indépendant je ne comprends pas tout le
monde parle de ça tout le monde dise que
les députés ne devraient plus voter leur
augmentation de salaire alors pourquoi
Québec solidaire qui était le plus
farouchement contre ne propose pas
justement dans une loi la création de ce
comité indépendant avec des critères
avec des règles puis est-ce qu'on revoit
ça aux deux ans ou 3 ans chaque année
est-ce que c'est l'indexation parce que
vous savez le salaire des députés là il
était vexé à chaque année c'est pas vrai
qu'ils ont zéro augmentation
le prix que moi j'étais payé en 2012
puisque les ministres gagnent
aujourd'hui il y a une différence c'est
pas exactement le même montant pourquoi
parce que c'était daxation alors Québec
solidaire aurait pu proposer toutes
sortes d'amendements qui auraient
rencontré leurs objectifs premiers mais
là en voulant jouer possiblement sur des
règles parlementaires mais d'offrir une
augmentation de 20000 pour a moins de
riz honnêtement ça me dit que certains
de leurs députés dans leur cocus
aimerait bien peut-être la voir ce 20
000 dollars d'augmentation
avec cet argent là non plus Gabriel
Nanou tu vois dis moi je vais te donner
une augmentation c'est libre et on dit
célèbre les députés vont choisir s'il
gardent l'argent ou s'il redonne
l'argent à un organisme quelconque alors
je trouve que Québec soldataire ce matin
a perdu beaucoup de points dans sa dans
sa logique de vouloir nous dire qui sont
contre par contre par contre le sondage
honnêtement ça c'est une bonne
initiative
monsieur Lego va voter quand même pour
l'augmentation mais attention attention
des sondages comme ça il pourra pas en
avoir très souvent et il pourra pas nous
dire monsieur Lego qui l'écoute la
population avec un sondage comme
celui-là
avec un sondage comme celui-là si vous
posez la question aux 74% qui est contre
l'augmentation salariale si vous étiez
député aimeriez-vous avoir 100 000 ou
130000 je vous assure que ce 74 % serait
très différent parce que ça dépend de la
question qu'on pose ouais ça c'est ça
oui oui
je me souviens à mon époque appelé
descendeur pour leur dire j'ai besoin
d'un sondage qui me donne le résultat
suivant peux-tu le faire s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
vous avez fait ça à vous
[Rires]
ne sont pas assez bien payés donc que ça
soit 10000 ou 30000 7 augmentations de
salaire selon moi et mérité et quand je
vois par exemple le PQ qui dit
donnez-nous en plus ce que vous allez
donner dépendamment avec au négociations
avec la fonction publique ceux qui sont
sérieux sur leur position qui disent à
perpétuité
après 2026 on va le prendre le 30 mai
additionnel si c'est pas bon aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas bon non plus à partir de
2026 après la prochaine élection
générale ok donc vous trouvez que ils
sont pas conséquent dans leur dans leur
opposition c'est ça Dimitri mais ils
essaient certains partis essayer de
faire du capital politique aujourd'hui
par exemple
mais à partir de la prochaine
législature si c'est trop aujourd'hui
30000 de plus c'est trop dans trois ans
aussi
le projet de loi qui est seulement deux
articles étant commission parlementaire
d'accord donc on discute de chacun des
articles et Québec solidaire fait ce
qu'on appelle du filibost c'est à dire
l'obstruction présente plein
d'amendements puis ça provoque des
discussions en fait je vous dirais que
c'est l'événement le plus divertissant
de la colline parlementaire en ce moment
voici un extrait de ce qui s'est passé
jeudi entre Alexandre le duc de Québec
soldier qui essaie de faire du temps
donc il veut parler et puis il veut
poser des questions ministres et le
ministre qui refuse d'embarquer dans le
jeu écoutons cet extrait
je pose une question ministre
est-ce qu'il est intéressé à faire des
audiences
pas intéressé ou pas intéressé à me
répondre est-ce que le ministre à
l'intention de prendre la parole dans le
cadre de cette étude détaillée je vais
intervenir lorsque jugerai pertinent
intervenir manifestement Québec soldat
veut faire une guérilla ça leur
appartient mais je ne jouerai pas dans
ce film-là
du ministre est plus intéressant que mes
questions c'est correct on commençait à
noter le nombre de questions que je pose
au ministre et à laquelle il ne répond
pas bon puis on est rendu à quoi 17 18
on approche tranquillement du 24
c'est le numéro du projet de loi donc il
y avait comme ok pendant 15 16 17
questions d'affilée Simon genevara tu ne
réponds pas Françoise moi je suis un
défenseur du travail en commission
parlementaire ok je me dis il fait il se
fait du beau travail en commission
parlementaire mais là est-ce qu'on n'est
pas en train de tomber dans le mauvais
côté du de la joute parlementaire
totalement puis je blâme les deux côtés
il est en passant
chacun joue son jeu on peut on peut se
fusquer de la réaction de Simon Jolin
barrette mais fidèle à lui-même
quelqu'un qui me dirait aujourd'hui que
Simon Jolin barrette a pas une petite
dose d'arrogue et puis il y a une très
bonne idée une très bonne opinion de sa
personne et de ses capacité je pense
même pas qu'il serait insulté qu'on dit
ça de lui c'est le personnage c'est lui
dans toute sa splendeur à ce niveau là
aujourd'hui j'ai utilisé l'expression
piratage aujourd'hui il a utilisé
l'expression piratage politique pour
parler de l'obstruction du Filibus de
Québec solide exactement mais c'est
aussi une bonne guerre de l'autre côté
vous le dites vous-même un projet de loi
avec deux articles c'est assez limité tu
peux pas présenter je sais pas c'est à
Québec c'est la même chose qu'à Ottawa
mais comme mes collègues tantôt
parlaient de peut-être prévoir un comité
indépendant l'intérieur sauf que c'est
pas l'objet du projet de loi tu peux pas
changer la nature
le projet de loi qui est devant la
Chambre des communes je sais pas si tu
as le droit de changer de A à Z le
projet de loi Québec mais j'en douterai
alors en termes de procédures sont un
peu limitées reste que le montant parce
que c'est à peu près ça que le projet de
loi dit on augmente et on augmente de
temps alors tu joues avec les avec avec
les chiffres c'est pas édifiant de voir
ce type de commission parlementaire si
j'étais le gouvernement qui veut aller
de l'avant à tout prix qui sait qui l'a
l'appui du parti à tout le moins du
Parti libéral du Québec ben il devrait
faire ça le plus rapidement possible
parce que ça sera pas très beau à voir
pour la démocratie par ailleurs je vais
quand même m'exprimer quelle sonde quel
montant d'argent gaspiller que d'avoir
commandé ce sondage là
alors que la grande nouvelle de la
journée va être Québec solidaire veut
pas 30 000 mais veut 20000 je me suis
levé ce matin en me disant waouh
beaucoup Gabriel Nadaud Dubois puis ça
gagne va faire les manchettes avec un
sondage pointage maison le sondage Léger
qui démontre qu'on savait tous en
passant comme demandé son épaule à tarte
aux pommes elle vous compte la hausse
des salaires des députés on le savait on
savait ça serait quoi la réponse sauf
que le sérieux du sondage la qualité de
la firme qui est prise etc ça leur
donnait beaucoup beaucoup de vent dans
leur voile et là tout ce qui le fait
parce que j'ai écouté la même conférence
de presse de Michel et j'avais
l'impression d'avoir un chevreuil devant
un chat parce que il savait plus comment
expliquer pourquoi moi j'ai pas trop de
présente des amendements 20 000 pour
jouer le jeu de la commission par le
mentale mais mot
votre peau en faveur c'est tu défais ton
argument à ce moment-là présente puis
votre compte ou bien ça soit conséquent
ben oui alors c'est un beau coup d'épée
dans l'eau c'est assez malheureux à
Dimitri qui parle son temps nous dire
que en 2026 c'est quoi la différence
mais enfin 26 la population va
s'exprimer sachant cette fois-ci qui
aura cette augmentation là et là à ce
moment-là tu peux te sentir un petit peu
plus à l'aise de prendre la hausse alors
qu'ils ont tous été élu sous d'autres
conditions de travail et ça mon point de
vue c'est peut-être là que il y a une
logique de ramener ça rapidement Dimitri
donc tous ceux qui vont se lever pour
voter contre vont aussi donner une
garantie qu'ils vont redonner le 30 000
tu peux pas te lever pour voter et
ensuite et ensuite encaissez le chèque
ce sera intéressant pour le pour le
gouvernement ils ont fait des calculs
semble-t-il ils pensent que ça passe par
les voies naturelles de du débat
parlementaire donc adopter d'ici le 9
juin pas de Baillon on verra si ça prend
les forceps justement
[Rires]
bon alors vous savez moi je suis très
indépendant dans ce déballage je suis en
désaccord avec tous les partis je répète
je pense que député devrait être payé
une fois et demi le salaire moyen c'est
la moyenne 50 000 ça devrait être
excellent là-dessus bon alors mais je
peux juger la qualité des uns et des
autres ce que je trouve extrêmement
désagréable dans le projet de loi du
gouvernement c'est non seulement qu'il
l'applique immédiatement plutôt que à la
prochaine législature moi je comprends
très bien cette logique là de le faire à
la prochaine législature donc on se vote
pas nous-mêmes mais on va pour la suite
c'est que le rapport indépendant qu'ils
ont eux-mêmes créé disait que ce chiffre
là de 131000 était fixé sur le niveau 4
des administrateurs publics et devrait
ensuite être lié à ce niveau-là donc le
comité disait nous ne nous reposez plus
jamais la question pour l'éternité ça
devrait être lié à ça mais le
gouvernement ne met pas cette clause
dans son projet de loi il fait juste
mettre le chiffre et d'accès d'accent ça
veut dire qu'il se donne l'obligation de
revenir dans une coupe d’année pour dire
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire de plus alors
ça je trouve que c'est vraiment même
lorsqu'il se gargarise en disant on fait
juste appliquer le rapport c'est faux le
rapport vous disait de continuer de de
fait de mettre cette balise là vous ne
le faites pas premièrement deuxièmement
sur la question des sondages moi j'étais
au bureau du premier ministre
effectivement c'est un privilège de
pouvoir demander des questions de
sondage et il arrive qu'on pense qu'on
va avoir la réponse parce qu'on dit bon
on est sûr que l'opinion est d'accord
avec nous donc on va faire exprès de
poser la question et de donner le
sondage à Sébastien Beauvais ça arrive
que c'est vrai ça arrive que c'est vrai
oui ça risque de les sondages m'est
arrivé puis c'est pas la réponse que je
voulais pas arriver sur mon bureau
[Rires]
alors il est peut-être quelque part dans
les archives on va la retrouver mais sur
la question du sondage Léger de ce matin
moi 74% j'ai trouvé ça plus élevé que je
ne pensais moi aussi je me serais
attendu à 57 62 74 c'est un gros sillon
et le vrai chiffre ça va être le
prochain sondage Léger sur la
satisfaction du gouvernement et
l'intention de vote de voir si la carte
a encore perdu deux points ou c'est
maintenu malgré des événements plutôt
négatifs alors sur la question de savoir
la gestion du filet bostrueux alors le
viliposter nous on le fait une fois
lorsque j'étais là si j'étais chef on
était contre un projet de loi libéral
qu'on considérait trop dangereux pour la
liberté d'expression et on s'est dit
nous on va tout faire que ça passe pas
alors ce que tu fais surtout quand tu es
dans l'opposition officielle chaque
amendement tu déposes ouvre une période
de discussion de 20 minutes ok tu fais
des amendements sur chaque adverbe tu tu
changes la conjugaison des verbes etc
pour faire en sorte que chaque fois des
minutes monsieur je l'ai barrette a bien
compris lui il veut pas
occuper le 20 minutes donc il répond pas
parce que ça veut dire que toi tu lis
des discours de grands
sociaux-démocrates qui sont pour la
liberté d'expression puis tu occupe ton
temps et si tu veux faire un vélo sur le
salaire des députés tu dis ok ben je
fais un amendement pour augmenter de 1
dollar 20 minutes 1 dollar 15 20 minutes
tu dis pas 20000
[Rires]
à faire ce matin j'en reviens pas
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI